turning now to the war in ukraine a
convoy of united nations inspectors is
due to arrive at a huge nuclear facility
near the front lines today
amid concerns about a potential nuclear
disaster we've been telling you about it
but the russians who control the
facility have threatened to restrict the
team's access deborah patta has more now
from inside ukraine
nuclear inspectors led by rafael grassi
on one of the most important assignments
their organization has yet to undertake
their mission is urgent to prevent a
nuclear accident and dangerous there has
been
increased military activity
including this morning until very
recently a few minutes ago the risks are
very very high
still
myself and the team
we believe that we we can proceed with
this we have a very important mission to
accomplish
the facility and surrounding areas
continue to come under shelling with
both sides trading blame and today one
of only two operational reactors at the
plant was shut down due to fighting in a
recent strike ukraine accused russia of
hitting the town where the plant is
located
it's enough to blow radioactive nuclear
waste warned local resident anatoly
scolatsky and it won't be pretty for
anyone the team of inspectors must cross
from ukrainian held zafarija into
russian occupied territory to get to the
nuclear power plant fears of a radiation
disaster are so high that ukrainian
officials hold regular emergency drills
to prepare for the worst
grati's team needs at least until the
weekend to evaluate security and damages
but locally installed russian
authorities say he has just one day
to finish the investigation
for cbs morning's deborah patter kiev